In this lecture, we continue our
discussion of continuous
random variables.
We will start by bringing
conditioning into the picture
and discussing how the PDF of
a continuous random variable
changes when we are told that a
certain event has occurred.
We will take the occasion to
develop counterparts of some
of the tools that we developed
in the discrete case such as
the total probability and total
expectation theorems.
In fact, we will push the
analogy even further.
In the discrete case, we looked
at the geometric PMF in
some detail and recognized an
important memorylessness
property that it possesses.
In the continuous case, there is
an entirely analogous story
that we will follow, this time
involving the exponential
distribution which
has a similar
memorylessness property.
We will then move to a second
theme which is how to describe
the joint distribution of
multiple random variables.
We did this in the
discrete case by
introducing joint PMFs.
In the continuous case, we
can do the same using
appropriately defined
joint PDFs and by
replacing sums by integrals.
As usual, we will illustrate the
various concepts through
some simple examples and also
take the opportunity to
introduce some additional
concepts such as mixed random
variables and the
joint cumulative
distribution function.